bonjour katia vous êtes donc à la
manifestation parisienne quel en est le
programme le programme après avoir
quitté république 7e se diriger vers la
place de l'opéra
les avocats ont répondu en nombre à un
collectif sos retraite ainsi que
d'autres professions libérales 18 ans
tout en haut vous citiez les médecins
mais il ya aussi des infirmiers
mon thérapeute qui est expert comptable
les métiers de l'aérien vraiment des
métiers hétéroclite mais tous menacés
par la baisse des pensions et la hausse
des cotisations
du côté des avocats et bien tous les
barreaux sont représentés ici mais sont
pas forcément présents ils sont
représentés de toute la france c'est une
mobilisation historique pour une réforme
extrêmement contestée ici dans les
champs le bruit il ya des personnes qui
tapent sur des casseroles qui ciblent
beaucoup de chansons je vous propose
d'écouter la présidente du conseil
national des barreaux christiane
féral-schuhl que nous avons interviewé
tout à l'heure cette réforme de la
retraite c'était la réforme de trop mal
engagée pas abouti et d'ailleurs
hier au sujet vous savez tous la durée
du congé parental de cinq à douze jours
la minus du travail a indiqué comme on
vote se justifier parce qu'on savait pas
comment financer les le fait de passer
de cinq à douze jours donc a fortiori on
peut imaginer que la réforme des
retraites qui est la réforme dont on
vous dit qu'elle est la plus importante
depuis 100 ans
eh bien on n'a pas de garanties sur le
financement et nous ça va mettre en
difficulté au moins 50 % de la
profession d'avocat mais ça va mettre en
difficulté l'ensemble des professions
libérales
prenez le cas des infirmiers et des
infirmières j'ai discuté avec des
kinésithérapeutes avec des
ergothérapeutes
alors soit on décide de supprimer ces
métiers mais ce sont des métiers de
proximité
donc cette mobilisation s'est rappelé la
place qu'occupe
ces professions nous sommes 18
profession rassembler et nous aimons
notre métier notre engagement
vous voyez une réforme contestée dans
son ensemble par la présidente ici
évidemment les avocats sont très
déterminés et ce à la veille d'une
rencontre avec emmanuel macron pardon
avec edouard philippe le premier
ministre afin de négocier éventuellement
ou de faire procéder au retrait de cette
réforme qu'il s'agisse des avocats ou
des autres professions libérales
aujourd'hui la tension est grande dans
les esprits le tout quand même dans une
atmosphère extrêmement détendu et on
suit la situation ici merci à catia pour
toute cette précision